harmonic convergence has caused a shift
in the planets energy I can feel it we
are entering a new age hey youtubers
it's Charlie I hope you guys all
survived Black Friday since we've gotten
some good details on Legend of Korra
book 3 I thought I'd do the top 5 things
that are going to be changing from book
2 to book 3 as well as some of the
thoughts that Michael Dante DiMartino
and Bryan Konietzko had about book 2 and
some of the things I said about books 3
and 4 going forward so quick update on
the production status of Legend of Korra
book 3 as of New York Comic Con this
past year they were about halfway done
animating book 3 and they finished the
story of book 4 no release date has been
announced yet but I would expect that we
might see book 3 as soon as spring or
summer of next year and then about 6 to
8 months for book 4 I'll be sure to post
an update as soon as they announce that
be sure to subscribe to get it I'll also
be doing all kinds of weekly Korra
videos going forward so let's dive deep
into the top 5 changes that are coming
in book 3 number 5 no more teen romance
so Konietzko basically said that fans
got so upset when they try to do these
fun teenage romance stories that we
basically would not be doing that going
forward so if you really hated the
McCory
and the Masami stuff you are in luck
there will be none of this in book 3
since Korra and Maiko did break up at
the end of book 2 and book 3 will pick
up a couple weeks after that they might
mention it in casual conversation but
the story won't focus on it in a big way
like it did in this past season number 4
earth Kingdom so if you noticed a lot of
things in Korra mirror the Avatar cycle
so it's air water earth and Fire so book
1 was air book 2 focused on the Water
Kingdom book 3 will focus on earth
Kingdom and then book 4 will be a fire
Kingdom story number 3 lots more Bumi
and beifong
so Konietzko and DiMartino said that
there will be tons more Bumi they didn't
say what he would be doing in book 3 but
we know because it's going to be an
earth Kingdom story that we will get
more beifong we still have no idea who
her father is so hopefully we'll find
out in this next book and outside of
team Korra she'll be one of the bigger
characters during book 2 she kind of got
pushed to the sidelines so that's gonna
change in book 3 number 2 Korra will
still be cut off from her past avatars
and all the changes at the end of book
to the spirits being in the physical
realm will stick so what does this mean
core is going to have to learn how to
become the avatar without the benefit of
the other avatar
but that does not mean that she cannot
get wisdom from ancient think so
spirits are generally immortal so she
can still learn things from ancient
spirits it also means that people like
iro can help her out too so we saw a lot
of iron at the end of last season I
think that was a one-off
I don't think iro is going to be joining
team avatar again but I do think that
she'll be able to seek wisdom from him
whenever she needs to if you're still
confused about the past avatars in Korra
now the past avatars did not die they
were not erased from existence whenever
raava died Korra will still be able to
learn things about them she'll just have
to learn it through other characters she
won't have direct access in her memory
like she did before and the number one
big change coming in book 3 the central
conflict will not revolve around korra's
bending abilities or her ability as a
bender at the end of book 2 she
basically learned to energy Bend which
is the most difficult form to master
that's not going to change in book 3
she'll still have all of those abilities
so her journey will be a much more
existential one she'll have to learn to
live in a world just like avatar Wan
lived in where spirits were living
harmoniously with people the transition
won't be an easy one so the early
episodes will mostly deal with people
getting used to spirits living in their
backyards and again whoever or whatever
the Big Bad ends up being her ability to
defeat that or overcome that challenge
won't depend on her ability as a bender
if you saw Thor the dark world loki
tells Thor in the movie you can't solve
all of your problems with hitting it's
gonna be just like that Korra will not
be able to punch her problems away I
know all these things revolve around the
Avatar cycle so would it be crazy in
book 4 if core became a fully actualized
avatar like the perfect avatar and then
another hundred year war started I don't
think that's gonna happen but wouldn't
that be totally crazy so in relation to
that Konietzko and DiMartino said that
after book 4 they will not be doing more
avatar obviously nickelodeon hasn't
ordered a book 5 they've ordered books 3
& 4 so we'll definitely see those but
this that they are so fried from doing
Korra for the past several years that
they're basically gonna go on extended
holiday so series 4 will basically be
designed like a series finale like a
total series finale not just a season
finale like it was this book but just
like avatar last airbender whatever ends
up happening to Korra she will still be
able to live on in the comics so in
general I think that all of the changes
that they're making in terms of getting
rid of some of the teen romance stuff
and making Korra journey much more
existential and less punchy
I think it's a really good thing
honestly it's really hard for you to
just keep providing the same challenges
for a character and for the story to
feel fresh so where do you take things
after you kind of master the physical
world you take it into this really
existential in psychological place so
we're gonna see a much more
psychologically driven Cora in the next
book which I think is really exciting
but let me know what you think what are
the things that you're looking forward
to most and which characters would you
like to see come back remember the
spirits are now in the physical realm so
we can see some of the big spirits from
avatar last airbender like I've said
previously since we have a little while
before book 3 starts and since there's
not going to be a lot of new news for
the rest of the year I'll be doing a lot
of weekly Korra bonus videos be sure to
let me know in the comments what kind of
stuff you'd like to see in those videos
I'm also still trying to decide what my
new anime series is going to be right
now Fairy Tail seems to be a really
common suggestion from you guys but keep
sending me your suggestions and I'll try
to keep you posted on what I ended up
deciding right now click here to watch
my review of the book 2 finale and click
here to get my latest Game of Thrones
Season 4 video for joffrey thanks so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives